الهدنه الثالثه عشره المتعلقه بوقف اطلاق
النار بين الجيش والدعم السريع في السودان
ازدادت اعداد الفارين من القتال في
الخرطوم وولايه دارفور ففي شرقي ودار فورد
تتجه يوميا عشرات السيارات الى دوله جنوب
السودان عبر الحدود البريه تنقل مواطنين
من شمال السودان وجنوبه الى جوبا
الحمد لله بسلامه
فكانت الاوضاع في نيال مزريه صراحه لكن
الحمد لله قدرنا نطلع منها والله الحاصل
ما بخفى على الزون طبعا يعني
الاشتباكات الحاصله بالسودان وكده الحرب
العباسيه زي ما بقول
منير احمد خرجت من منزلها بالكلاكله
الجنوبيه الخرطوم بعد قصف استهدف مكان
سكنها تقول انها عاشت اياما قاسيه مع
صغيرتها لتقطع ما يزيد عن الف كيلومترا
وصولا الى الضعين ومنها الى جنوب السودان
رحله تظل عصيه على النسيان في ذاكره منيره
حرب طلعنا بره
ما بطلع لكن لمن هاجر تحملناه كثير قلنا
خلاص
[موسيقى]
ويواجهه الفارون من القتال في السودان عده
مصاعب من بينها انعدام الامن في الطرقات
وارتفاع تك اليف السفر اضافه الى صعوبه
التواصل مع ذويهم في بعض الولايات وللاسف
الشديد انه للان انا اخبر اسره اسره عندي
الموجودين في
منذ
اسبوعين وحاجه انه اخبرنا ما عندنا لانه
عدم وجود الشبكات
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ما في عشان يعرفوا لنا حتى التقارير زاد
وما في وتعمل منظمات اموميه على استقبال
اللاجئين والعائدين الى ذنوب السودان في
الحدود بين الشمال والجنوب لتوفيق اوضاعهم
تندرج شرقي دارفور تحت قائمه الولايات
الامنه لذا اضحك معبرا مهما لغربيه
السودان والدول المجاوره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات